今日は中学生の枝はじめです今日はよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
実は26歳で表記が中学校だった頃に僕の学校の先輩は強い人が多かったです族 new
不良です中学生なのに髪の毛が頻発とか茶髪の人が多くてリーアンランとかおんたん
っていうズボンを履いたりしてとっても怖かったです運動会や文化祭で暴れていて
ちょっとワクワクしましたダメなんですよねそれでよくないと思うんですけどもあの
当時の僕には刺激的だったという話です上でヤンキーっぽい中学生今ちょっと実在する
かわかんないんですけど実際にいるんですよっていたんですそんなためなおさらの
ポイントとしてはもうアクセされなきゃアクセサリー北中学校の授業もクリームソーダ
なさい掘ってたらかっこいいみたいな風潮があってそういうのが
れであのチェーンが蔵に前とかつけて再パケっていうんだってたらめっちゃカッコイイ
みたいのがあったんですよなぁこれつけてる先輩イター
チェーンですねこんなの付けてたら怖いじゃないですから通学をなされて強ければ
かっこいいんですよねこうやって作って愛で誰だねだこれもれこれを中学生はこれが
あったらフっぽいんですよもうもう中
楽天のヤン品の世界で言えばチェーンつけてかっこいいですよ
でも今ドルは中国製ではないな大人
こんな国だったらもう2学校の頃だったら買えないぐらいのチェーン帰るんでちょっと
金がたくさんちゃいました
すごいおっぱい雲仙たねチェーンっていうのはなつければつけるほどかっこいいという
わけでこんなちょっと楽団なんですけどもう楽団にランキーのチェーンで何個まで
つけれるのか試してみようと思いますまずにある家で千切れたら格好悪いですよなんで
潰え限界ここがどれだけ耐えられるかだと思うんですよねこう次れない限定レベルまで
知恵をつけて
今日史上最強にカッコいい
神学生200円を目指してみようと思いますでバイク
最も下がってみます
まぁだいたい200g 位ですかね-2桜舞台なので号個つければ1 k 無事なり
ますじゃってるかー
1個目ま1個付けたところじゃ全然ちょうどいいぐらいですねちなみ願いだったかっこ
いいと思うんだよな
ヤンキー的には2個目
正直痛い2個付けてこれですからねある形にはなった声運ん夏希かつ奴はおらんと思い
ますけど
もうなんか弱いみたいになってきましたねまあまあ22巻ですねシャア
4つ目なんかかっこいいなここまで来ると後米路面7個目9 comments 何個
つけたっけ待ったらやばいなこっこれが大きいからねなんかなぁ今橋公開8個ついて
ます
事故でも結構思えてこれ9米10個目やばいもう10個つけたらいいな僕に行けるたい
すべてますからねやっぱりクシかっこいい気がすんだけどなぁ
これがそれにヤバイんだどんどん行きましょうジョイ米中23
141510-1718中級に十分
にズッコつきました54キロのチェックがついてますねやばい度も覚えですね
なんかワンちゃんちんちん出しても見えだけならぐらいの各せる要素
な見えるなこれまたさすがにもうちょっと日や思想でね会える思い出ヤンキー中学生と
してはなかなか泊のある姿になったのではないでしょうか
どんどん行きましょう2120人中3位14位15
二十七二十八3月30今6キロの重りが付いておりますも学ランちゃんと来ても隠せ
ないくらいなんじゃないかの捕鯨やばいなもう先生にばれちゃいますねこれだとし経大
付がくらんだともうね引っかからないってこことか見て立体機動装置みたいなってるん
ですよまあ刻んでどんどん増やしていきましょう
一に
g 3初 a 3 b 級品ズー
関心がござい排水でヨンジュンのつきました妹8老眼ついてますねどんな付きますので
自分で見て下さいます4 q もムツ六へぶんず7分発セレブ系もず
チェーンだけ10キロありますハハッもうすごいよもうすごいけどもう在家そうねただ
こんなヤンキーやもいません
別にポケサー水よ556円ズー
nia 卜筮
やばいこれはさすがにはじめ焼き興津です助けるのが結構精一杯で来ないいやあこう
下旬色の線をつけてますね
僕は体を隠しきれませんこれはをご覧くださいもう結構尻ゲイなんですよ結構危ない
ですだが粘っててまだいけそうですねまぁだけどでどうもやっていきましょう
6全治6時に遅れ寒く14 e 000000602
ん
あっ告げ14キロのれるからもうなんかマジでやばいんだよな
結構限界に近い気がしますもうちょっとだけ聞いてみましょう71
すげーすげーすげーなずに見てもうメッツ切れて戦っていますもうなる引っ張らないが
力が強い時めっちゃ動いただけがヤバイ
[音楽]
バッハとれいちゃんのどれ全部取れちゃうかスタッフを張ったままですやだよここが先
に次れましたねてございまほとんどの胎児がここに伺ってみたところです
いやーん
[音楽]
me
car